don't have sex in bars just drink have
fun and go home the best way to get a
drink or a shot for free is in someone
that comes in often and tips us well if
you treat us well we treat you will it's
really that simple
be a big tipper I always remember that
tip bag I always get him a shot or buy
him a drink
learn the bartender's names like get to
know them when it's not super busy and
make a connection like we're more likely
to share a drink with them the worst way
to get a free drink is to ask for one by
the way I can give you other stuff for
free other than free drinks a lot of
times that will get you free food or
snacks
something like french fries that's a
total lie asking for no ice or less ice
does not change the other ingredients of
the drink nothing else changes you're
literally just getting less ice which is
exactly what you asked for
I don't know less ice just means
disappointment most of the time you get
less in the cup or you get a smaller cup
unless you tip and then that changes
everything
when customers ask for like a stronger
drink
I just put like two or three drops in
the straw just to make them think it's
stronger just it kind of burns the back
of their throat go back to be a month we
put of alcohol will be the same no
matter what you have you can always pay
for a double shot or you can have the
cup full of ice and then it's less mixer
which will make the flavour of the
alcohol stronger it sounds like they
want something strong but they don't
want to pay for it if you want a strong
drink to sport or a double this this is
my number one kept you yes I see you
you're there there's people that are
also here waiting for my attention this
is not helping okay when people say oh
just fix me something that like your
favorite drink to have no what I like is
nothing to say what you're gonna like
and nothing to say what your best
friend's gonna like or what your mom's
gonna like most the time just gonna end
up giving you a vodka soda a splash
crime area if you wave your cash or snap
at me or do anything of noxious anything
that like you as a human being would
find annoying you're gonna get less
attention if you snap at me you're not
getting sir
like point-blank and the period it's
always the people that like schmooze you
those are the worst tippers your
compliments and like your love for me
doesn't pay my bills the best way to get
a bartender's attention is to look at
them and smile it's like I mean when you
meet somebody for the first time the
best way is just to look like you're
ready
most the time bartenders are scanning
their section of the bar to see who's
ready who's not so we're always looking
for you
don't worry if you'll send they're
waiting catch my eye make sure I saw you
and then you're good patience is
rewarded behind the bar wait your turn
don't worry I will get to you you will
get your drink you'll be fine
nobody's gonna say no to like a
handshake with something in it hash is
always king like oh it's the cash if
they did a really bad job and you didn't
have a lot of fun give 10% if they were
fine and you were kind of okay get 15%
and if they did a good job and you had a
good time
you should give 20% if it's a decision
that you make flavour sense a good place
do I drink on the job no yes always
every single time I like to call it
quality control oh my god can't get me
fired I used to a lot I can finish a
whole bottle of Jameson before I even
sell one I make more money not though I
just want to make you have a drink what
you want to drink and if I can make it
I'll make it free
[Music]